this guy must have had the best mom of
all time to think he could get away with
this lie I didn't go to college but um I
turned it down oh yeah I turned it down
just to do this just to grind from the
rap so you uh had an opportunity to do
the drug thing a scholarship and
everything we're at
um I think it was like in Jacksonville
yeah big a big band in Jacksonville it's
a big college though a lion and they
offered me like 15 something like 10
million or something like that five
million something like this so different
a scholarship
okay but not five million dollars
15 asked me 15 offer me 15 10 million
five five million dollars or something
like that hey man you're not
175 years old you remember you're 30.
dude after you five million dollars
what the [__] are we doing here before
y'all like that's what I'm saying but I
was so younger like wait wait wait I
didn't know what it was are you sure the
average you five million dollars
down
it was a scholarship like I had to go to
school for this decade
this guy know what a scholarship is [__]
this guy's talking about employment dude
this is such a I had to go for college
this decade I had to go to college for
this decade right to get paid at it was
15 or 5 million dollars
I didn't go to college but um I turned
her down oh yeah I turned it down just
to do this just a grand front rep so you
had an opportunity to do the drug thing
the scholarship and everything rap
um oh god dude where'd you get a
scholarship from
um dude making it up
the city he picked was perfect though
because it's a big city that nobody
really knows about Jacksonville you know
if he was like
honestly any other big city would have
[__] up Chicago oh well what is it oh
no Jacksonville be like people give you
Grace with that
I think it was like in Jacksonville
you know big a big band in Jacksonville
it's a big college though and they
offered me like 15 some [__] like 10
million is what I did five million
something like that
a scholarship okay but not five million
dollars this is the the best part this
guy's so good at like this guy had the
best mom of all time because he he he
his mom was always like you know you
could do anything and you're the best he
would trip and fall and she would be
like that's the ground fall honey
like this guy just believes in himself
whatever he's saying no matter what
55 million dollars that my favorite part
is when he goes
yeah what the [__] are we doing here
like that's what I'm saying but I was so
younger like so yeah are you sure they
average you five million dollars
down
[Laughter]
so I turned it down
dude
I want to be why can't I be friends with
guys like this
I try
I try to be friends with guys like this
you know
but it's like
I can't because they're just utterly
[__] terrible you know what who is
this guy a football player rapper
because he would get a scholarship for
sports right not for rapping but he said
I'm in his rap game
I mean this guy's so confused you know
that's the best lie I've ever heard in
my life and it's such a good lie that I
believe him
school for this decade
it was a scholarship like I had to go to
the best was
the face when he realized he could say
he had to go to school for the decade
like he's like oh I could get away with
this
I turned down Kelly